[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we welcome in ross tucker the former nfl
offensive lineman host of ross tucker
football podcast and he'll be working
for westwood one
he'll be working the sidelines for the
afc title game
kickoff will be 6 40 eastern on sunday
ross do we know if this is a concussion
with patrick mahomes
it evidently dan is not a concussion
having watched
a couple times i think that he had
momentary trauma to the carotid sinus
area where the vagus nerve and boro
receptors
are located and i think what happened
was really
a vasovagal reaction
are you reading something
[Laughter]
that's uh i read that i read that this
morning from
dr david chao the 20 years he was the
chargers team doctor
he doesn't think mahomes actually had a
concussion
he thinks basically ever sees like a
martial artist or a cop or whatever hit
someone like here
he thinks that when mack wilson came up
with his right arm
and hit him and he said in 20 years he
never saw it in football
but based on the different reports that
are leaking out and the video
that's what he believes happened and he
doesn't think mahomes will have any
problem
getting cleared because he doesn't think
he really had a concussion but also he
has to go through the concussion
protocol
how long does it take you to go through
the protocol
i mean you can say look i don't have a
concussion but if you're in the
concussion protocol you have to go
through the required steps don't you
yeah and one of them is a full practice
so i don't think
we will hear that he is cleared until
friday afternoon maybe saturday morning
because they'll probably take it easy
with him today maybe he does a full
practice thursday
then he meets with the independent
neurologist and i know dan there's a lot
of conspiracy theories out there i i
understand that
but they do real they really do have
independent neurologists they're not
affiliated with the team
and those people have to clear them and
they do that for a reason they want to
make sure there's somebody
who's not affiliated with the team
because there'd be a heck of a lot of
pressure
on that team doctor if that's who was in
charge it's really
out of everybody's hands other than that
independent neurologist at this point
can you hide a concussion nowadays
yeah i think you can um you know
you can't hide what happened to mahomes
where he you know he obviously stumbled
to his feet
and i actually think dan even if
whatever dr chao
said even if he's cleared i gotta think
like i can just picture
my mom right dan saying that boy should
not be able to play football
i saw him wobbly on his feet last sunday
he should not be able to play i can just
picture a bunch of people my mom
included believing after what they saw
last sunday that that young man
should not be able to play tackle
football a week later
i don't have a problem with it as long
as the independent neurologist
clears them but to your point yeah i
mean look i had at least three
concussions
as a player dan never diagnosed never
said anything about it
really back then unless you were knocked
out
and this is only to 2008 but unless you
were knocked out
or you said something there really was
no way
for them to know i remember one time
sitting on the bench and one of the
practice called offensive line was like
tucker you okay
and i was kind of in a in a fog there
for a good three or four minutes
drew bledsoe thrown interception like a
total idiot i tried to make the tackle
and roosevelt colvin
blindsided me the first thing hit the
ground was the back of my head
and i was kind of in a daze for a good
three or four minutes but other than the
one practice squad oh lineman
who saw me got k saw me get killed he
was the only person to even talk to me
about it
what if mahomes can't play what are
their chances against buffalo
well the only thing i would say is two
two factors in that
number one henny played really well i
mean henny did a lot of really positive
things he had one terrible interception
i have no idea what was going on there
but he played pretty well
the other thing is sometimes when
there's a backup quarterback like that
i feel like number one the other guys
rally around him and play better and
number two
whether it's conscious or subconscious
it just seems like sometimes the other
side
i don't know i don't i don't say they
let up but
it's like okay it's not my homes it just
it changes things a little bit i will
say this though dan um
chad hennes from my small hometown uh
why i'm missing pennsylvania he went to
wilston high school
i i've known him for a while i used to
work out with his dad
and you know the way it is i'm sure this
happens to you all the time dan where
people tell you their kids are let me
tell you about my son he's gonna be a
good athlete
i remember working out with chad honey's
dad when i was in college he's like yeah
i think my son's gonna be pretty i'm
like yeah
i'm sure he's gonna be great turns out
he started four years
for one of the top ten schools in
pennsylvania and then four years at
michigan now he's in his 13th year in
the nfl so small world
we're talking to ross tucker the ross
tucker football podcast he'll be on the
sidelines the fc title game with
westwood one
how important is this game to tom brady
to his legacy you mean well i brought
this up
that his age a year removed from the
patriots
you just beat brees if you would happen
to beat aaron rodgers
at lambeau when rogers is playing at an
all-time level
he's your mvp i'm not even getting to
the super bowl yet
but i i don't know if i'm overstating
how big of a game this is for brady to
do what he's doing
if you factor in the other elements here
of no longer with the patriots first
year with tampa bay age 43
on the road and you're going to beat
aaron rodgers at lambeau
am i overstating it no i don't think you
are i mean
look the only arguments people have left
against brady wright is that it was
it was all belichick and coaching and
that he's a system quarterback blah blah
blah
which i both are laughable but whatever
if he beats aaron rodgers the mvp
at lambeau to go to a tenth super bowl
with a new team even those morons will
have to shut up at this point right i
mean even those people
won't be able to say it but to be honest
i feel like he's kind of already done it
i mean the patriots had a five-game
deficit from 2019 to this year
the bucks had a four-game improvement
and i know the rosters aren't totally
the same but let's be honest he
he's the major reason for that and now
to win
two more playoff games to get to a
a 14th conference championship game i
mean
think about this he's been to 14
conference
championship games in the 19 years he's
been a starting quarterback that's
74 it's absolutely insane
and and frankly dan for all the people
with the system quarterback
argument or the belichick argument well
i i don't
i guess brady brought the system to
tampa and new england stopped with the
system i i don't know or for the
belichick thing
do you realize belichick has one
playoff win in the eight years
that tom brady was not his starting
quarterback i mean there's a that's a
decent sample size now for belichick
without him
by the way philip rivers announced his
retirement earlier this morning we were
debating
i guess the debate is first ballot hall
of famer
what do you think i don't think he will
be no
i don't think he will be because number
one i think drew brees
would be ahead of him if if drew brees
retires as expected so
as far as a first ballot guy and
roethlisberger if he
happened to retire correct and not only
that
i don't think eli manning necessarily
will be a first ballot hall of famer he
might he might not
so it might be what would that be year
two or year yeah i guess year two
for eli and there's not a good argument
for rivers over eli manning there's just
not
so i i don't think rivers get i think he
eventually gets in sort of like dan
fouts did but i don't think
rivers is a first ballot hall of famer
no i don't think he will be
but if i said you could have been rivers
or eli as your quarterback
for a decade
ben won for sure
those next two guys are tough those next
two guys are really really tough
uh i think i'd probably i feel like
we're a little bit skewed based on
how the last five years went for rivers
and eli
if we're talking about their first 10
years or 10 years in the prime of their
career
prime prime i'd probably go eli
because you know i think people forget
rivers
like his first few years dan they were
loaded
i mean they were loaded they were i mean
antonio gates and
ladainian tomlinson the o-line was
awesome sean merriman and i mean
they were loaded and for whatever reason
he wasn't able to get it done
to get to a super bowl and when eli did
it twice hard to take that away from him
i think we got some really interesting
off-season situations obviously with
desean
watson there but the saints
quarterbacking situation the colts
quarterbacking situation
what's going on with the eagles what's
going on with the bears
dak prescott coming back with the
cowboys jimmy garoppolo's future
in san francisco i mean there's a lot of
moving part what the patriots are going
to do
the number one quarterbacking situation
that you
would love to have an answer to right
now is what aside from deshaun watson
yeah i was gonna say watson because i
feel like he's the domino that
everything else
uh ha you know comes off of um
you know i'd love to know about new
england but just knowing them dan
and what they look at in terms of value
i think that they'll kind of wait it out
i think that they'll kind of see
what happens with these other things
with jameis winston
and other places before they pounce
i guess i'll say indy and i'll say indy
because i feel like philadelphia is
directly related to it
because there's a lot of people out
there that seem to think the colts
want to get carson wentz to reunite him
with
frank reich and i saw reports this
morning
that that's what carson wentz supposedly
wants again that's just a report but
that's what wentz supposedly won so i i
think probably the colts
because they're a playoff team they're
very good
and they might go and potentially get
the quarterback from the eagles which
then
i guess means hertz would be the guy in
philadelphia
have fun this weekend safe travels
always great to talk to you thank you
buddy
yeah my pleasure i'm sideline duty dan
but
i'm not actually allowed on the
sidelines so i think i might be getting
paid
to sit in the third row and have a beer
and a hot dog hopefully we'll find out
thank you ross ross ross tucker ross
tucker uh
football f podcast you'll be on the
sidelines for westwood one radio
where you can't be on the sidelines
because you have to be in the stands all
these reporters
sideline reporters aren't on the
sidelines when they report